hey what's going on it's Bill bur and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for
Monday um January 8th
2024 oh my God we're almost halfway
through this decade where is it all
going um how's it going man how was your
weekend was it good was it nice was it
too [__] short
um we should do a Hunger Games thing on
[__] corporate CEOs just throwing it
out there I never saw Hunger Games but I
I believe it's human beings hunting down
other human
beings you know like how long are they
going to get away with you know it's you
and somebody else in your department and
then they fire somebody don't replace
them with anybody and expect you to do
your job and then their
job and then with the money they save
they give themselves a
bonus um or they put it towards AI all
right Bill Let's you know it was a nice
weekend let's let's not begin the week
this way okay fair enough fair enough
I'm sitting here in my office SL garage
SL uh you know Man Cave thing here and I
am I am watching low resolution NFL
football the [__] Bills versus the
Dolphins as far as I know the last game
of the year I do not think there's a
Monday night game and uh my [__]
satellite dish has been [__] up since
I don't since I don't know how long I
know you go oh what the you still got a
[__] satellite what do you got what
do you go I watch the games on my phone
oh do
you I zap it down and then I [__]
shoot it onto my TV oh that's fantastic
you're amazing did you invent any of
that enough
already I tell you what's bugging me is
all these different American flags all
these [__] [__] saying that
they're Patriots and within their
country country they're coming up with
their own America that has their own
American flag it's just another thing to
divide people there's one American flag
get on the [__] same
page you know stop with the third Jersey
American
flags I always like you got to sit there
and be like what does that mean and
you're somewhere you know somewhere it's
you always feel like it's it's the clan
adjacent or something I always feel like
it's some sort of disgruntled white
person that feels their countryes being
taken away from them which it is by Rich
white people but no no they're the same
color as me they wouldn't do
that it's got to be this different
colored person who has absolutely no
[__] power whatsoever just like me
but even more so even less so um
anyway
um the hell was I going to talk about
before before I went on before I went
down that [__]
Road
um I don't know I have no idea I don't
know anymore I spent the whole day with
the kids I'm [__] wiped out I'm
breaking a New Year's resolution I'm
having my second cup of coffee
today
um just cuz I I just they they wore me
up they [__] wore me up we woke up
you know my son came in you know he
crawls into bed he's kicking me he's
hitting me in the head and all that [__]
it's like 10 7 so I'm like all right we
get up and then I go let's go out to
breakfast and then let's go out to
breakfast then led to taking him to the
playground which was great this
playground I I'm glad I went back there
I had a good memory cuz last time I went
to that playground I got involved with
uh somehow I became it and I was chasing
the kids around and in my head I saw the
other parents looking at me and I
thought that they were thinking wow look
at that guy what a great dad he's so
involved what an active dad and it's
such an advanced age too wow he he's
really really
inspiring and uh then I ran around the
corner there was like some slime and I
[__] totally wiped
out and uh didn't hit my head but I I
landed hard on my forearms and one of my
shoulders I felt it and I got up and I
had the big [__] skid mark on my
shin and then I real oh that's what they
were looking at they weren't looking at
over here cuz they were inspired they
were looking over here going what is
that old man doing he's going to hurt
himself and uh they were right so I
hadn't been back there since I was
embarrassed you
know it's like when uh Weber called that
timeout that they didn't have in
Michigan like that was my dad moment and
as far as I know he never went back for
the Fab Five documentry well you
know I decided I was going to face
calling a timeout when I didn't have one
which was basically running around when
I didn't I didn't I don't have any more
running around days left in my
life
like my running around is if if if the
whatever I'm in is on
fire somebody comes in starts shooting
or has a [__] a if I'm running for a
bear comes in and runs for for I got
start running for my life you
know you know what's funny I used to
think you know when I'm out here in La I
always think about mountain lions I
think about black bears but it's really
like
raccoons I feel like raccoons are the
ones that are going to get you cuz
they'll come into your house and [__]
start eating your Doritos like I've seen
it on uh on YouTube they sit right next
to you like
[__] like they're part of the tribe
you know and then you get familiar and
then next thing you
know they come at
you cuz I don't know you you you bought
Pringles that week or something and then
you have
rabies and I don't know how that works
how do they cure rabies I remember back
in the day it was like [__] 30 shots
to your abdomen or something that's what
kids used to tell me and each needle got
a little bigger it was agonizing and for
some reason they had to do it without
anesthetic now that I say it out loud
none of that makes sense but uh we did
believe
that back in the day so
um those are the ones I always worry
about like I'm not worried about
bears cuz I've watched enough videos on
it and evidently all you have to do is
be like all you have to do is go hey
bear
hey B don't you do and you go you just
kind of [__] you do like a mock
charge at them and they they [__]
walk
away but if you show
Fear if you actually deal with you know
if you actually mentally
think this thing has four Freddy Krueger
gloves that are part of his body so
they're not they're not falling
off
right and uh then he's got fangs and
he's just going to try to [__]
bite into my back until he breaks my
spine mercifully
mercifully
um God help those people with backpacks
just prolonging it he just goes for your
Goddamn face no I'm kidding obviously I
know a bear is dangerous I know there's
people out there that think people don't
know about these things on every
Wildlife video there always has to be
somebody explaining
it I know this is hard to see but this
is
nature oh my God just enough with that
stop holding my hand you're also on the
internet which means you're not in the
wilderness shut the [__] up um which I
should do more of in
2024 um I did my first solo
flight D
helicopter
uh on uh
Thursday and uh I did something I've
wanted to do for a long time where I I
transitioned over
LAX over pulva Boulevard at 2500 ft It's
[__] amazing and I did that without a
problem and then I did the the
harbor uh transition which is along the
110 you stay on the east side of it if
you're going north and they're both
really cool so there's three ways to do
it one is along the beach at a below 150
ft 2500 at seula and then at 900 ft or
below at uh the harbor transition each
one of them is cool when you [__]
you know going over the ocean at 150
feet and there's [__] Surfers and all
these people you gotta watch out for
kites there always some [__] with the
who has a [__] kite you know I get it
I have a satellite dish I don't have a
[__]
[Music]
kite I'm not that old maybe like some
[__] hipster where where do you even
buy a kite at a hobby store I I haven't
seen a hobby store in a long [__]
time I remember hob hobby stores were
for ugly people you
know Corvettes and cool cars those were
for older guys you know that were
crushing it banged a lot of broads when
they were single maybe was still tagging
their secretary every once in a while
they went out and they still had like a
look at me badass car but the guys who
never got any you know just sort of
midle middle of the road background
people
they always ended up at like it was
called hobby
town and you go in there and there would
be like these [__] guys it was
hilarious they go in there and they were
dressed like train conductors and they
had no license to drive a real train but
for whatever dumb reason they would buy
these toy train sets and they would have
like the [__] I'm driving a
locomotive hat
on they were sort of like sports fans
today back then where sports fans now
you know it's kind of less I
feel but it really got out of control
with people wearing the jerseys there
for a minute I think it's starting to
come back around now like maybe maybe
the kids can wear the jerseys huh you
know I don't know but these guys they
were doing it
before like when I was a kid like you
know if you went to a baseball game
somebody had you know there was like Red
Sox hats but it was mainly everybody
just looked like they just came from
work and they showed up it was
definitely it was like dressed down
Fridays is what baseball looked like I
missed like 20 years before that people
used to go to the games with like
[__] a shirt and tie on a
fedora um Everybody sitting in the crowd
looking like they were working for the
FBI um and then it became dressed down
Fridays they did that for like 20 years
and then eventually it just became let's
dress like the people on the
field and then somewhere in there you
know the culture of dressing like an
absolute [__] idiot it just so you
can get on
TV
um became the other thing to do what the
[__] is going on with that I hate this
[__] goddamn
thing you know it's like it Heats it up
and after it Heats it up then it then it
flips to the air conditioning I like I
don't know what it's doing I turned the
heat on cuz it was cold out here once it
gets up to
temperature turn it off oh Nikki Nikki
Nikki what happened I'm watching Nikki's
post
game old Nikki post game
what happened to the [__] Eagles can
some Eagle fan write in I don't have
time to watch the game there's no
[__] way they were looking like it
was them and the
49ers um not only in the NFC
championship game but whoever was going
to win that game was going to win the
whole [__] thing and then the wheels
just came up who got
hurt there's no way Nick forgot how to
coach and there's no way they all forgot
how to [__] play something
happened something happened dude this
was a tough week to bet huh Jesus
Christ half of these teams he's speaking
of dress down Friday none even showed up
Patrick Mahomes showed up in his street
cloth today can you imagine if you spent
all that money at the beginning of the
year you
know to to to take your kid to Sofi
Stadium to watch uh what's his face
versus uh [__] Patrick Mahomes the
guy who got hurt
amazing quarterback what the [__] his
name Josh Hartman right is that his name
yeah that's the game you thought you GNA
see Josh is out for the whole
season but at least I got to see Patrick
Mahomes doesn't even
dress he's on the sideline cheering
people on like it's all garbage time
Travis Kelce doesn't
dress it was like a [__] preseason
game so many of the games I lost my ass
this week I was trying to beat the book
on B MGM I was one game under I needed
to go three and
one um at least to beat him and I think
I went one in three I had the
Lions they showed up and played I had
the Browns they didn't [__] show up
who else did I have everybody I had just
didn't give a [__] I had the Bears
thinking the Packers were already in
they weren't going to show up but they
needed to win dumbass me so I [__]
lost that one then I had one other
one I don't know there was all these
weird
scores like Seattle only would played
the the [__] lowly Cardinals and only
one by one that means they sat everybody
right I don't know what happened I was
at a [__]
goddamn playground today so um anyway
what was I talking about I was talking
about people with
Hobbies oh my God what happened to Mary
letton that wasn't Mary letton was
it Jesus Christ
this is not oh my God Aaron Rogers and
Bill bich a
long a long hug there everybody taking
pictures thinking that's the last
time is that George stenopus am I nuts
did that guy used to be in the white
house I mean how the [__] did he end up
here that's like Michael
Strahan like you watch he's on Good
Morning America he replaced Regis
filburn it's incredible I would say
George
stenopus Michael strahad and when Snoop
Dogg did a show with that that cook who
went to jail Martha Stewart those are
the ones where I live long enough to be
like wait a
minute that guy came
out murder was the case that they gave
me and now he's making biscuits with
this [__] white lady from Connecticut
how the never seen a career like that
and George stepp he wasn't in the white
house he interviewed
people that's what he did wasn't he the
one that would before Clinton got
elected remember when Clinton and Al
Gore [__] ran and everybody thought
they were these cool young guys you know
because everybody was looking at uh
whoever who's the [__] vice president
under George Herbert
Walker the hell was his name that poor
bastard he used to [__] every week
he'd hold a gun backwards I mean when he
when he he was talking to some kid he
spelled potato and he he told me forgot
the e and everybody made fun of him and
I had to sit there in my head going like
I I thought he forgot the e
too I thought it was po to to
OE
um Dan quail and then all of a sudden
Bill Clinton and [__] Al Gore come
right and they got the [__] dunger
shirts on and they just look like a
couple of lugs that were working on a
car in a [__] garage and everybody
thought Al Gore was cool cuz they nobody
really had to talk to him and he was
just sitting up there
going right and you didn't realize one a
lunatic he was not how how much he was
in his own [__] head until he ran in
2000 with George stenopus was was was
one of the one of the [__] big press
people asking him questions like why
should you be leader of the Free World
whatever the [__] that means
right he was asking those
questions now he's doing football he
must have saw too much he probably got
sick of it after a while just going you
know I'm gonna I'm I'm going to get into
bread and
circus maybe maybe he saw which way it
was [__]
going Jesus
Christ I can't believe oh my God I just
wish I could fast forward through this
year when it comes to the presidential
election I mean Jesus Christ these guys
are so old they should be wearing
powdered
wigs
they should go up there in the debate
right they should go and they should
have the ruffled [__] shirt remember
that shirt Jerry Seinfeld wore in that
episode where he's dressed like one of
the Three Musketeers they have to wear a
shirt like that they should have
powdered wigs on with like the white
knee socks the knickers and then the
buckle shoes and then they come out
there instead of saying you they have to
say ye right ye will not talk tth to me
like
that
um anyway I mentioned I was breaking my
New Year's resolution I'm having my
second cup of coffee but this is this is
the second time I've done this I I you
know I got it pretty much under control
but I was [__] wiped out and I had to
make sure that if I was going to bring
the ignorance it had to be a high
level of ignorance um oh I think my
satellite dish is working it's not
blurry
anymore
um it is amazing how Josh Allen like how
how boyish his face is that dude
literally looks like he's like 12 years
old like a Manchild you know you ever
seen one of those bearded 12-year olds
they'd have like at the circus back in
the day step right up step right up see
the bearded [__] 12-year-old throw a
ball 60
yards well what would you want to do
that for well in the future there's
going to be a game called football yeah
um anyway I noticed Nick croll the head
coach of the go of the Dolphins he's
he's busting out the glasses I actually
went and I I finally got an eye exam
I've been telling you guys how much I
need I've needed
glasses um for a while now and uh you
know and there's this theory that if you
get glasses it makes your eyes weaker
now the people who were selling me
glasses tell told me that that was some
[__] and that's exactly how they
said it to they the doctor smoks and
they say yeah that's that's some
[__]
uh I was in a strip mall I mean this is
this is the kind of no I'm kidding they
didn't say that they said yeah that's
not true so I took the ey exam and uh
everything that I was told ended up
being
[__] they told me that I I had a uh
a Stigmata whatever the [__] it is this
this the
uh that thing in your eye which means
you can't [__] I know stigma is
uh is that the upside down cross there's
something on you
if you have it it's burned into your
skin it means the devil's inside of you
see people think you have to read you
don't you just have to watch The
Exorcist part two I think that's where I
saw it or you listen to uh
Ministry Gago um couple of 50-year-olds
got that joke
um yeah they said I didn't have one of
those I could get lasic and my thing's
like look you're not going to [__]
you're not burning off part of my
eyes with with a [__]
laser all
right what do you want information just
tell me what it is you don't have to
[__] what that sounds like torture do
you knock me out no you you're you're
you're awake you're awake just looking
at this [__]
laser um Josh why don't you throw a
[__] block instead of staring at the
guy Jesus [__]
Christ um stay don't yell at him he's
only 12 years old
um and then they said my eyes weren't
that bad and I was like all right so uh
I ended up getting some not some readers
I got like for like when I sit down
because I'm I'm going to read I say this
every year I'm going to read and uh I
got uh I'm reading this
book um I finished Reggie watt's book
and
uh I got this book from
uh I I don't know who the [__] gave it
to me I'm getting into this one it's
just like you know you know what I I
don't really even like when I lay in bed
I don't really need oh my God is it Bob
sledding this time of year
again I don't understand that does that
bob sled have
breaks how do you practice how do you
get into that that that [__] sport do
you just like drain the brake FL blew it
out of your car and just start driving
down Hills in your
neighborhood and if you don't die then
they stick you in that [__] sled no
they have brakes in the end
right I still I you know out of all the
Olympic events that's the one I I mean I
always love the bob sled event but I
don't understand it it's
basically suicidal
sledding it's not really athletic is
it you know didn't John Candy coach at
Jama Jama I mean right there right there
you know it's not a sport if John Candy
rest his soul the guy's a [__]
comedic actor and he coaches your
team um I'm just doing this because I
want people to push this slit actually
if you had any idea how many squats we
have to do each week it is actually
highly
competitive
um all right for the nine the drinking
game when bill says what the [__] was I
talking about yeah you have to do a shot
I like that I like when people have
drinking games rather than dealing with
their childhood
trauma okay we've all done it it's a
great thing to
do why look back at the past when you
can get [__] face now right when you
can annoy people and cause new trauma to
other people today me and my wife are
playing a game right now okay we have
we're having a contest I'm not allowed
to yell and she's not allowed to correct
me and you know what I loved about it
she was like all right all right I'll
take that bet like you know cuz she's
abroad so she doesn't think she does she
does anything [__] wrong so she
thinks she's going to win this thing so
right now we we're having like this is
like a pitcher duel it is zero to zero
for the whole day my daughter is keeping
score and
uh
is it correct me or tell me what to do I
for some whatever just pick something
just pick some [__] thing that they
do
um
anyway you know it's weird watching
commercials with the sound down I just
watch people in pink pants singing about
Pepto Bismol to some poor bastard you
know and he's all excited that he drank
it and he feels better but he's not
going to examine what he
ate you know to get like that that's
like people who like [__] eat RADS
every day it's like why don't you change
your diet dude you know oh speaking of
that I took a chance at a restaurant
today oh I took a
chance I threw caution to the wind like
my wife has been everywhere she's seen
all of this stuff she just goes out
there I'll give I'll try this out right
I'm a creature habit all right that's
that's a nice way of saying a [__] a
boring [__] so I
um I'm like you know I always see this
[__] restaurant on the way to my gym
I'm I'm GNA give it a [__] chance so
I went in there and I ordered some food
and
uh I ate it it was it was more like Mom
and Pop It Wasn't
outstanding but it wasn't bad either
right so I was like all right that's
that's [__] cool so
um I'm getting ready to take my kid to a
uh a birthday
party which is amazing right as I go to
leave right as oh my God you know I you
know the 1972 undefeated Dolphins I mean
Jesus have you seen the [__] I just
saw a picture of one of the guys that
was on that team he looks like they're
running back look like Tom celic and
he's carrying a striped
[Music]
football 17 games now get you out of the
regular season 17 and0 back then [__]
you you won the super you were done for
the
year um they got to change that you know
even like in tennis they have like the
open era versus back in the day don't
they I don't know it's [__] weird
anyway so I had this this
[__] this
food and
uh you know I just worked out it was
protein based or whatever and I [__]
eat it and
I thought I was fine and right as we get
the kids loaded in the
car you
know we're driving up the hill to get to
the [__] highway you know and
uh right as we go to get on the highway
I'm
like oh no and I just I feel it it's
starting to
churn in my belly
right and my wife goes do you want to go
back and I go no I can tell this is
something that's going to be talking to
me for like an hour before it it you
know it it just it's just it's going to
be like I'm not going to have a choice
if you know what I mean right so she
goes I should have listened to
her so then I drive like another two
miles down and within two miles at this
point we're too far away from the house
I go uhoh I go this is going to be a
[__] problem right and and she's like
well why don't you just pull over go
into the
7-Eleven and she I go I
can't and she goes why not I go you know
something somebody asked me one
time you know what's the drawbacks of
what you do for a living all right being
in the public eye this that the one
major [__] drawback everything is a
bonus except when you you're about to
[__] your brains out and you're in
public that's the because you're not
Anonymous you can't just go in and blow
out some [__] bathroom at a Starbucks
and then somebody leaves and just yeah
this [__] bald [__] went in there
before me no it isn't it's Bill Burr
went in there and [__] annihilate it
smelled so bad that he couldn't even go
in the ladies room
right so I went I dropped them off at
the party and I [__] turned the car
around like I was on Adam 12 remember
that they they were never going in the
right direction I was talking to
somebody about that the other day and I
just [__] whipped the car around and
I got back on the highway you know went
down the hill live at the bottom of the
hill down the bottom of the [__] Hill
right
um got into the house and just and and
just [__] made it and I was it
just and I was thinking to myself you
know this is
why this is why this is why I don't
[__] try new places I like this new
Bud Light commercial with pton Manning
and EMT Smith where they start you know
they got to buy everybody around now
because they put some transgendered
person on the can what the [__] were
they thinking you know what I
mean if you're all about profit like why
why would you why would you jump into
that it was one of the dumb things you
could ever do you know I'm not I'm not
like
trashing transgendered people but like
what what are you what are you going to
do next budlight are you going to try to
get rid R A Kick a Ginger
Day I mean you guys [__] up so bad you
got to like [__] throw beers at
everybody they're free now they're free
now come on come on you heterosexual
people drink our beer again come on
man
um there was yet another dumb thing
people got upset about like there's all
of this real [__] going on and that's
what you get mad at I'm never drinking
that beer again
there you go that'll make the country
better you dumb
[__] um Jonathan cry it's the amount of
people that are stealing my [__] look
I swear to God everybody's a [__]
bald white dude now with the beard
what's going on that was my [__]
thing that's the end of my acting career
now Jonathan I was getting all the work
Jonathan CER wasn't getting now he
[__] shaves his head now I'm done now
I can't be on [__]
uh hey swe sweetheart knock it off up
there whatever the name of that [__]
show was two guys in a [__] uh
precocious
kid the hell was that show called it was
on it went on forever it was Charlie
Sheen Jonathan
CER and then uh the kid from
Iowa the [__] the the the one of the
first actors I saw started his own
production company and started creating
shows the nice guy from That 70s Show
not the other
one Ashton
Kutcher Ashton
Kutcher
um you know what's funny there's a
[__] guy at my gym that looks like
the [__] dude that went to jail from
that 70 show it's [__]
hilarious I mean he like a Dead Ringer
he got the [__] curly hair and
everything first time I saw him I was
like I thought that guy I thought he got
convicted I guess he didn't he must have
a gig coming up he's here at the gym
trying to work out um what am I talking
about I don't
know I don't know who cares like you
know I love I love how the [__] you
know I the players actually won this
17th game of the year they really did
because they're all getting paid for it
and and it doesn't seem like many of
them are playing in it um but I guess
they would have done that during the
16th week I don't know what kind of
message does this send to the the Youth
of
America everybody takes the last [__]
work day of the week off is that how it
works um all right why don't I do the
reads why don't I shut my fat [__]
mouth and do the reads
um oh here we go all right here's the
live reads for 18 all right it's Helix
everybody Helix it's Helix sleep um
Elite
collection a mattress designed for Big
and Tall sleepers and even a mattress
made just for kids so how will you know
which Helix mattress works best for you
and your body um take the Helix sleep
quiz today and find the perfect mattress
in under 2 minutes and your personalized
mattress yeah you know what they do they
instead of scanning your Reta they scan
your taint which is sort of like the the
middle like uh it's it's sort of the
like the fulcrum like on a drumstick the
fulcrum of your body like when a grizzly
bear goes to pick you up and just Maul
you to death that's he picks you up like
a bowling ball um and your personalized
mattress but don't get upset I know this
is hard to watch it's just nature and
your personalized mattress is shipped
straight to your door free of charge uh
Helix knows there's no better way to
test out a new mattress than by sleeping
on it in your own home that's why they
offer a 100 night trial and a 10 to
15year warrant to try out your new
mattress try it out have a good time on
it everybody you know you don't like it
send it back gross they cut that out I'm
convinced they cut that out of my copy
because they got sick of me yelling
gross everybody is unique yeah yes they
are doesn't mean you have something to
say though and everyone sleeps
differently that's why Helix has se
several different mattress models to
choose from each designed for specific
sleep positions and free preferences and
if your spy needs some extra TLC don't
worry they got you every Helix mattress
has a Hy hybrid design combining
individually wrapped steel stigma in
your eye that's what it was coils in the
base with premium foam layers on top
it's the perfect combination of comfort
and support plus uh Helix mattresses are
American made they make them right
[__] here we got our own [__]
American flag for these [__]
mattresses that we make
right um that's not my bud lot uh plus
Helix mattresses are American made and
come with 10 to 15E warranty depending
on the model don't want to take my word
for it helex has been awarded the number
one mattress pick by GQ oo in Wired
Magazine it's even for people was that
for cokeheads it's e it is even
recommended by multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine as a go-to solution uh for
improving your sleep uh Helix is
offering 20% off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com and use the code Helix
partner2 h e l iix p a r t n e R20 this
is their best offer yet it won't last
long with uh Helix better sleep starts
now and lastly but not leastly the old
ride or die been here forever stamps.com
everybody once again signing up for the
podcast they don't give a [__] what I
say I love these people stamps.com New
Year is full of surprises but one thing
is predictable postage costs will go up
again in
2024 ask not what your mailman could do
for you ask what you could do for your
Postal Service stamps.com gives you
crazy discounts of up to 89% off USPS
and UPS services so your business will
barely notice the charge with stamps.com
all you need is a computer and a printer
they even send you a free scale so
you'll even you'll have everything you
need get started take care of your
taking care of your orders on the go is
easier than ever with the stamps.com com
stamps.com mobile app if you need a
package pickup you can easily schedule
it through your stamps.com dashboard and
if you sell products online [__]
relax stamp.com seamlessly connects with
every major Marketplace and Shopper and
shopping center I don't know what that
means running low order shipping and
mailing supplies labels and even a
printer from the supply store got huge
career uh carrier discounts up to 80 get
sorry get huge carrier discounts up to
89% off USPS and UPS rates to help your
bottom line for more than 25 years
stamps.com has been indispensable for
over 1 million businesses we [__] get
it uh take a chunk out of your mailing
and shipping costs this year with
stamps.com sign up with the promo code
Burr B RR for a special offer that
includes a 4-we trial plus free postage
and free digital scale no long-term
commitment or contracts just go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top of the homepage and enter the code B
um all right I think that I think that
that's it with that right what else did
I want to talk was there anything that I
wanted to talk about that I didn't get
to before I get to my
listeners
um oh man I did some standup comedy I
went down to Lago on uh Sarah Silverman
show Todd Glass was down there just a a
bunch of [__] hilarious people and I
got to mop up at the end and
uh I'm telling you this new 15 minutes
that I am I am I am grinding down honing
and all of that it's some of my most uh
most fun I've been having in a long time
and uh I canot I'm actually as much as
I'm enjoying being
home um I can't believe this I'm 55 and
I'm [__] psyched to go on the road
all right I'm not going to lie to you
when January first happened I was like
starting to get depressed like oh God
another year on the [__] road here we
go you know and then uh all it took was
one or two good sets and I'm like hey
hey I have something new to say I'd like
to share
it um and then I'm going to a bunch of
fun places I'm going to Portland Oregon
I don't know when I know I'm going there
and I had the best steak of my [__]
life the last time I was there and now
it's cold in here again so now I go over
and I turn it back on
again Jesus [__] Christ what what
what what kind of world do we live in
now I set it at 70 and then it gets up
to
70 you can't go above 70 right your
[__] balls will
evaporate that's a thing too evaporating
balls but you know they don't really
talk about it in the mainstream media
because it affects men but I can tell
you right now if women's balls wherever
they are all the way up inside of them I
never took an anatomy class I know they
have some
things that we have they're just inside
I don't [__] know um I know they have
two butth holes one's bigger than the
other is that right
um sorry it's one the grossest things
I've ever said
um where am I where am I what am
I yeah if it affected women God knows
you know there'd be a color everybody
had to wear for a few weeks
you know like you know what's never
going to catch on is growing a mustache
in November you know people just like
doing it because they have a Halloween
party coming up right and then they just
keep it for [__] November and then it
makes it look like you give a [__] um
how is that not
Nate Nick croll not Nate Craig Nick
croll coaching the [__] dolphins all
right let me get to the let me get to
the
reads okay so if you're new to the
podcast you [__] write it to me for
whatever reason you ask me me questions
oh new shows added would you look at
this Phoenix Arizona April 27th at the
Arizona Financial Theater San Jose
California June 24th uh 1st at the San
Jose
Civic I'm going to say
Center uh both shows uh pre-sale start
Wednesday January 10th at 10: a.m. local
time with code bur bu St Louis Missouri
March 22nd at the fox theater pre-sale
starts January 11th at 10:00 a.m. local
time with the code Burr all shows on
sale to the public January 12th 10:00
a.m. local
time all right let me take a sip here of
the coffee the [__] funny
juice oh by the way um there's a master
class coming up with this guy's teaches
you how to uh do the Barista [__] I'm
going to try it because I I I watched
this thing I got great advice on how to
uh steam the coffee like I was steaming
it and then adding the air and then
steaming it up until I couldn't touch
the cup which means it's pretty much up
to temperature this guy's like no you
put the bubbles in first I was not doing
that that might be common knowledge to
you but I was not doing that and I had
the best looking like I just did it like
the best looking like steamed milk it
had that consistency I just don't know
how to do the art yet but I'm I'm right
there with the consistency I'm very
[__] excited and uh that's just one
of those douchy dad adult things like if
you just could [__] make somebody a
cappuccino and do the little [__] uh
you know Freemason sign whatever the
[__] they do down at those coffee shops
it would be really cool and I am also
slowly turning into one of those Geico
dads I met someone at a coffee shop we
were writing some [__] and I was I went
back up
um to get a water right and uh this
woman brought a cake out from the back
and there was this I thought it was a
younger woman but wasn't she was about
my age a little bit younger and she saw
the cake and she went ooh to her friend
and without even thinking I'm like oh
don't do that you have that you're going
to have to take a
nap and she just looked at me like why
are you talking to me and I wanted to be
like because I'm 55 and I'm
happy I'm happy with what I have I've
let go of what I thought I wanted and
I'm just [__] having a great time and
I'm in a Jolly mood I'm sorry and I
understand you have most of your life
still ahead of you so you're [__]
you're in a different mindset and I'm
sorry I did everything but my one of my
favorite Geo dad moments is when the
person's backing in that you don't even
know and you start trying to help them
into the spot uh you got it you got it
just come over there it's like who the
[__] is this guy um I am becoming
that um
you know what it is it's because the
older you get the less threatening you
are when you talk to people so right now
I'm in my my you know I'm an old guy but
I'm still I'm just coming off as a
weirdo all right where women used to be
scared if you like just sort of
approached him and you had my [__]
I've been hurt as a child walled off
emotionally shut down energy they'd be
like is this guy a serial killer now I'm
sort of Jolly but still you know little
[__] up you know I'm like a recovered
cokehead you know like a you ever talk
to a recovered Coke head/ alcoholic just
the way they talk and their emotions
they're like a blown speaker you know
you can still hear the music but there
you just know a lot of bad [__] happened
well I feel like in the next 10 years
I'll just be I'll become
adorable that's what I'm counting on um
so I just have to work this is like this
your my second like adolescence awkward
years um where your adolescence you was
slowly become what the [__] is he
doing he's just [__] slinging it
what's he bitching at the ref
now um
gout uh okay here we go this is from the
listeners gout hi angry Billy Ginger
balls um can you at least call me less
angry so I feel like I'm
progressing uh I've Rel I've relatively
speaking only recently found you on
YouTube I relatively speaking don't you
just say relatively
speaking
no recently I found out about you on
YouTube relatively speaking parentheses
two years
ago I've relatively speaking only
recently I've relatively speaking only
recently Jesus Christ I'm [__] got
vertigo about two years ago and found
your podcast about five months ago but
that's
brilliant I'm a Brit trucker oh there
you go this is my people
all right summer school on the other
side of the pond I bet you're a funny
bastard I'm a bit Brit trucker but
actually now live and work in New
Zealand lucky you man that seems like a
peaceful place uh Trucking down here I
only listen to podcasts and audio books
and music I've downloaded your show is
literally the best podcast in the planet
plus a bonus for me you know I bet he's
got big fat trucker thumbs that's why is
writing this weird uh plus a bonus for
me I have thousands to catch up on well
that's what a [__] nice guy other
side of the world opposite hemisphere
takes the chance takes the time out to
say thank you or whatever he's saying
he's saying he likes my podcast I
appreciate it um I'm not a doctor but
you briefly mentioned you get random
shooting pains in your big toe a week
ago I do too and it's
gout now I'm not a doctor but get it
checked out checked mate no no no no I
said it went numb it's my sciatic nerve
I don't have gout I I didn't I didn't
party to that level and I also know I
know people with gout and it is so
[__] painful they can't even have a
bed sheet on their
foot
um yeah I have a good friend of mine
that has gout it is it is it is not
something you want to be around um
yeah it's like passing a kidney stone
that never passes it
seems
um anyway yeah no I I don't know I
believe it or not I've actually been
pretty healthy my whole life um just out
of vanity you know and also you know I I
knew I was a weirdo you know I didn't
just walking around looking like a freak
I didn't need to be a fat [__] a fat
freak I mean who wants to be that right
uh right kids throwing rocks at
cars is that
back uh hey Billy love
handles you know I can't wait for you
guys to see me on tour with my revenge
body um I was listening to last week's
podcast and somebody asked for a legal
way to stop people from speeding down
their street I have a similar issue but
with kids throwing rocks at cars is it
weird that that may be
nostalgic wow I thought once they had
video games that one that's one of the
best things about video games and people
jerking off on the internet they don't
have the time to go outside and just
throw [__] at your car when you go by um
it's been reported in my neighborhood
lately that there is a group of kids who
purposely wait for cars to drive past
their house and with no regard for
anybody will Pelt the car with rocks
cans bottles Etc but mostly
rocks I don't mean to laugh but we used
to do that and I'll tell you right
now most people would slow down like
what the [__] but when you got that
lunatic that pulled
over we had a guy that chased us in the
[__] snow it was like a horror movie
he just kept
coming um and we ended up breaking off
he ended up catching one of my friends
but we had to [__] split up this guy
just was not
stopping we were sledding we just threw
a snowball at his car and he just he was
[__]
livid and he ran up that [__] Hill
and we were running away laughing and he
just kept coming and the
Laughing you know switch slowly into
screaming into
crying cuz we were
like I mean [__] I wasn't even in the
second grade um anyway it's been
reported in my neighborhood lately that
there's a group all right the local
police have been notified multiple time
and refus to do anything about the issue
because the kids are
underage what however it's been said
that the adults in the home are aware
that they do this and egg them
on it's hard for me to believe the
police wouldn't do anything to adults if
it was a ticket or something I feel like
something has to be done am I nuts oh
dude this is one of the easiest
Solutions
ever this is what you do all right you
got to have one car in front of you
that's the Mark I believe they say on on
a sting right that's like you know when
they have the police officer and they
dress her up like a [__] you know and
then she's got to walk down the street
trying to [__] bait the serial killer
and then before then the serial killer
grabs her and before you can [__]
kill her you know and turn her skin into
a [__] uh sweater vest they're
supposed to come in and arrest the guy
so you basically do the same thing you
have the car go down the street you know
and then a car behind
you have one of those [__] the AR-15
version of a paint
gun and then what you do is you just
[__] open up on those kids and you
[__] Pelt the [__] out of them all
right then here's another thing you find
out what house they're in and at 3:00 in
the morning you go by with the paint gun
and you [__] right through the
[__] Windows just pick the living
room nobody's in there and if the guy's
asleep on the couch he's got the back of
the couch to cover him all right all of
that was a joke I don't think you should
do that I'm not advocating that that is
all very
[Music]
dangerous um that was a that was a
Revenge fantasy I don't think that you
should do that um all right but how much
fun would that
be you know be better if they had a
[__] paint gun that was like one of
those old school machine guns where you
need one guy to feed the [__] ammo
into it so you could both enjoy it like
in the back of a pickup you know get
some get some uh living with an X oh my
god wow I mean going through a breakup
is hard enough but to hear the the the
next guy [__] your ex-girlfriend and
somebody's going to be getting laid
before the other one right and God knows
it has to be her it's going to be even
worse
right be even worse for you right all
right living with an ex God damn it that
that [__] cappuccino is
delicious um hey Billy
blueballs I recently broke up with my
ex-girlfriend of nearly 3 years after
over a year together I generally thought
I found the one and we co-signed a lease
on an apartment together unfortunately
the last year and change was pretty
Rocky in spite of us working towards a
future together and even looking at
engagement rings last month but the [__]
all culminated right before the holidays
and her breaking up with me then taking
it back repeatedly telling me to fly to
my hometown without her for Christmas
getting mad at me for actually going
through with it and also trying to
convince me to get a tattoo of her
initials on my
ass all right buddy you know what the
great thing about me not being in this
relationship is in and everybody
listening is we have
Clarity yeah uh
congratulations congratulations um and I
would get out of this [__] apartment
as soon as you can uh side note you may
you must be
thinking uh you may be thinking we must
be certified pre-owned white trash no I
don't I just think that uh she was
[__] your brains out and at some
point that made sense cuz the [__] was
that good not to be crashed but that's
what we think on the contrary we both
just turned 27 I'm an engineer making
over six figures what in the [__] are
you still doing there get out I don't
give a [__] if you still have to pay
half the rent for 6 months go live in
some [__] hole just to not be there just
get the [__] just get the [__] out of
there get the [__] out of there pay your
half of the rent go move back in with
your parents get the [__] out of there
uh I'm an engineer making over six
figures while finishing a master's
degree and she is finishing her pharmac
Pharmacy
doctorate um oh great nice level-headed
person going to be giving drugs to
people and the AC's back
on I don't know why it does this is
there something wrong with the
thermostat is it on that Eco [__]
[__] this is
genius it's just genius it makes you
keep turning on the [__] heat
shutting it off I don't know I don't
know what the deal is um anyway let's
get back to this [__] guy making six
figures you got the
cash Make It Rain and get the [__] out
of there um anyway uh we're both tall
and in good shape we have been are you
guys like AI robots like you guys don't
seem
possible uh we're both tall in good
shape and have been called a power
couple on multiple occasions which
probably contribute to that that we are
both pretty
egotistical all right I'm starting to
lose empathy on you here all right so
you're Barbie and
Kendall any anyways while I got some
space from her over the holidays I did a
lot of research about how to handle our
underlying problems strategize how would
communicate with her and even send her a
love letter in an effort to be a good
boyfriend we agreed it was time for me
to come back and we would try coup's
therapy uh Al last the first night I got
home she blew up on me egged me on to
break up with her and so I said [__]
trying to make this work and ended it
good for you in the coming days she said
she doesn't want to break up kept
double-checking that I was sure and it's
been struggling to accept where we're at
buddy get out of that [__]
apartment after we broke up I offered to
absorb the full cost of the
apartment
why why because you know why cuz the
cops believe her because Hell hath no
fury I am I'm so sick of this [__]
narrative that the the amount of
[__] advantages in relationships that
women have
normally you
know I mean unless your guy is like a
[__] wife beater like you you're
going to
win I mean I don't know cuz what you're
doing is what I would do I just I just
you know I'm sorry it broke up with you
I'll [__] pay for everything you can
stay here I'm going to get the [__] out
of you that's that's how we look at you
guys when you get upset and you [__]
know it um I'm going to absorb the full
cost of the apartment and take her name
off the lease if she moved out oh you're
going to try to keep the apartment which
she is declined since she can't afford
to live by herself and so I thought we
would work things out as roommates for
as long as we could handle it however
today she asked me to move out and
continue to pay for my half of our
apartment now [__] you because she
wouldn't be able to get past our breakup
if I was still here and because she
would eventually throw a fit if we were
still living together for too much
longer I can afford to Cave into her
wishes and just be done with it without
having to deal with the psycho but I
really don't want to basically pay her
to live in a 1200t apartment by herself
for the last 6 months of our lease what
should I do uh you should break your
lease you should break your lease and he
could go all the
way there you go this is what I would
do
okay um
this is what I would do I would get
another place to live sign a lease there
I take a day off from work without a
realizing it I would pack my [__] up I
would get it the [__] out of there and
then I would tell the landlord that I
moved out that we broke up and I moved
out and I'm not [__] paying anything
else and let him do whatever the [__] he
wants to
do I would I would
not you
know but I get it if you do this I get
it but this is just this classic [__]
thing that when a relationship [__]
ends a woman feels well I need to get
something out of
this right and the level of power that
they have now with social media to say
and you you you were abusive and all of
this [__] you know it's Pro I mean I'm
coming with like [__] 1980s 90s
advice
here so
um I don't know in the in the dream
scenario that's what you do I would say
this um either way you need to get the
[__] out of there you need to get the
[__] you need to get away from her as
soon as possible and you need to get
another place as soon as possible I
would just get the [__] out of there
just get the [__] out of there and just
and and I would just say uh and then
once you have your own place you can
kind of negotiate like no I'm not doing
that she's a pharmacist she has [__]
money you're an adult
just say no I'm not doing that just say
I'm not I'm not paying this I'll pay
half of it that that that's way you do
it don't do all that psycho [__] I said
just say listen I'll pay for half that's
it okay I'm not I'm not you you are an
adult and I'm not paying for that and
just remain
calm like it's like I lost two years of
my life just like you did like why don't
you pay for my half of the [__] rent
[__] you take out all of that and the
attitude no F bombs none of that [__]
and just yeah it's [__]
annoying it's [__] annoying you know
why it's annoying cuz like I don't know
whatever the [__] Audacity Of that I
can't deal with you being here I
wouldn't be able to get over with pay
for my
life all right all the ladies
independent throw your hands up at me
every [__] hand goes up and they all
play this [__] game or at least a lot
of them do all right Billy
putty Billy putty not silly putty Billy
putty uh dear Billy putty you've
achieved great success your microphone
reaches many people could you please
take a second and ask these [__] that
are working the gas stations convenience
stores to go ahead and unlock both entry
doors to The
Establishment for [__] sakes do they
enjoy watching a couple hundred patrons
a day do face plants into the glass
doors
we can do better USA well it makes for
great
videos yeah why is only one open I I I
don't understand that either that is a
decent question um all right that is the
podcast everybody um I got to go get the
kid kids
uh ready for bed here another NFL
regular season is over it was a great
one and as always I bitched moaned and
complained about the prevent defense and
nobody cares and it continues so I am
done yelling about that um that is it I
got I'm doing the Bon Scott gig with
Dean Del Reay I'm playing two songs I'm
doing my new 15 minutes and all of that
[__] uh I know that part's going to go
well we'll see how the rest of it goes
um I almost said I love you guys what's
going on with me what's going on with
new Happy Bill the Geico
dad um how you doing there uh Kissinger
what what the [__] you supposed to say
to kids Kissinger went with a [__]
war criminal
um but aren't we all war
criminals we just don't fight as big a
battle that [__] chick that dude's
living
with i' throw her in there um anyway all
right that's the podcast go [__]
yourselves and I'll check in on you on
Thursday